when I said I wanted to win eight gold
medal is basically half the people in
the swimming World thought I was
absolutely crazy and nobody could ever
do something like that but for me I was
somebody who believed in it and somebody
who believed in the process of getting
there I knew it wasn't going to happen
overnight like I said before but every
little small thing that we did was the
small stepping stone in order to in
order to even be able to have that
chance and that opportunity to to do
what I did in 2008 so
it was 2014 Sports Illustrated cover
story with Tim Laden and we're having an
interview here in in Phoenix and
whatever whatever question he asked me
just opened me up
dropped my shoulders and I just let it
all out
um I was just ready to you know I think
for me when I checked myself into to get
treatment and to get help
I knew that
that's what I needed and and I was at
the end of the road and I had to get
help I was at a scary place in time
um and for a long time I didn't know how
to ask for help
I think once I asked help for the first
time everything became easy so that
question when he asked me whatever it
was it just opened me up and I felt
comfortable to share everything that I'd
been through because it was almost like
I I said to myself I don't care what
people think this is me and this is my
journey and it makes me who I am so you
know the only way for me to learn and
grow and and to get over certain things
that I've gone through to communicate
and talk about it and and look I'm not
perfect right like nobody's perfect and
and I struggled a lot through my life my
first impression swell is in 2004.
um and I went up and down roller
coasters all throughout life
I think it's vulnerability I think
vulnerability is a scary word for a lot
of people it's a scary word for me you
know I remember when I checked into a
treatment center I was shaking when I
went in there because I didn't know what
I'm getting myself into but
I wanted help I didn't like feeling the
way that I did every day is a new
challenge right every day as a child is
is a day that we can
prepare ourselves even more so for us it
was we would call it putting money into
the bank so at the end of the year when
we had a major International competition
we could withdraw that money that we had
saved throughout the year and look I'll
be the first one to tell you there were
a lot of days where I did not want to
get out of bed
and I guarantee you if I ask the
question here if everybody is excited to
get out of bed every single day if I saw
a hand I'm going to blatantly call you a
liar
because we all know that is far from the
truth but if you have those little small
goals those little small things that get
you excited when you don't want to it's
going to make it even better and even
easier at the end when you're getting
ready for a presentation or the end of
the year or this or that whatever event
you're leading up to it's going to make
it so much easier and I think if you
look at the greats and anything that in
any Walk of Life
the greats do things when they don't
always want to
and that's the separation
for me that's what I've found so you
know when I say from 2002 to 2008 was
basically trial and error so for me in
2002 that's really when I started amping
up my event schedule where I was
swimming
four to five individual events and
having a couple relays at Pam Pack's
World Championships major International
competitions throughout those that time
frame because at that time at the
Olympic Games
that's a tough I mean that's where I
think the real truth comes out because I
think there are a lot of people who are
very talented who can make it there
there are very few people who can deal
with the pressure and the stress that
happens when we're there so that's why I
say we had to make sure that we were
physically emotionally and mentally
ready because I had to be ready to be
able to kind of manage my emotions
through that week yeah winning a gold
medal is absolutely incredible there's
nothing better than standing on the
podium listening to your national anthem
play after you had just won a gold medal
but for me I'm somebody who I knew that
I had
seven other events after the first day
so I have to throw that in the back of
my head I Gotta Throw That race out even
though if I you know even like you know
wait I broke a world record one goal you
know won my first gold medal like I was
like cool like things are starting
really well so I have to put that behind
me to then get ready for the next race
uh and on top of that I have to make
sure I'm eating the right amount I'm
sleeping the right amount my body is as
fresh as I can possibly be so that means
sitting in an ice tank getting massages
getting stretched all of these small
things that end up adding up to the
major end result and because I can sure
as hell tell you that there were days
where I hated my coach
there were days where we got in fights
we got in arguments we couldn't stand
what we were doing I would do things
purposely to piss him off but that's a
different story
but you know I think that was that was
just really how we worked like he was
somebody who was so perfect for me that
if if I ever swam for anybody else I
would never would have had the chance to
do what I
did because he challenged me in ways and
forced my mind to think differently you
know for me as a kid growing up I was
I'm huge into music and music is a big
part of my life and I'm a huge Biggie
Smalls fan and and he wrote a song
called the sky is the limit
and as a kid growing up I believe that
I believe that whatever I put my mind to
and if I was willing to make sacrifices
and I was dedicated that I could achieve
absolutely anything I still do
I think every person can
really Define it in their own way I mean
I think it kind of really determines
what they want you know at the start of
it for me when I started this whole
journey it was with a goal of of
breaking a world record winning an
Olympic gold medal becoming a
professional athlete those are the goals
that I had as a little kid so for me
that was what Excellence was and once I
was able to get there I had to redefine
what Excellence was and that's basically
what I did my whole life so for me I
guess it was kind of goals because goals
were something that played such a huge
part in my everyday life
from the moment I woke up to until the
moment I got into bed they were
somewhere where I could see them every
single moment when I was in my home
um
that's what really got me out of bed
that's what helped me on days where I
was struggling
um so yeah so I I think goals are are
what really drove me and what made me
try to become as excellent as I possibly
could so I came back from the 2000
Olympic games uh as a 15 year old and uh
after the Olympics is usually when
people take time off where they take a
break they relax for three to six months
and then they get back into it for me I
was into it the next day after the final
of 200 fly I was fifth place I was three
tenths out of a medal I was upset so I
use that as motivation leading into the
next year and the very first day that we
had a practice my coach put WR on the
top right hand corner of the paper WR
meant world record I was a 15 year old
kid I was like oh yeah I know what this
is but why is this what's this doing
here like why are you putting this in
the upper right hand corner it's like
we're gonna break a world record in six
months sure enough six months later I
break my first world record
so I'm like okay like this is starting
to get
really cool like starting to get fun and
by this point every world record I broke
I got to buy something that was my deal
I was a I was a professional athlete at
15. I had signed my first professional
deal so when I signed with an agent at
15 I told him that I wanted to change
the support of swimming so I wanted to
do something that the sport had never
seen but people had never seen the the
globe had never seen and to be able to
have that opportunity I had to be able
to do things differently I couldn't I
couldn't do it the same way that
everyone had done it before so for me to
go five or six straight years that meant
I had 52 extra days a year so but also
in the sport of swimming if you take one
day off it takes you two days to get
back to where you were
so somebody takes off on a Sunday
they're not back until Tuesday
so they're only getting Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
as where I'm getting
six years straight so I'm getting that
much more ahead of them I'm getting that
much more work I'm in that much better
shape and that's what I had to do